let's get to hatred mail for the weak
hatred mail is when when a professional
voice-over artist interprets the hate
mail that I get here's a little bit more
information about hey treat male because
thoughts and prayers are bulletproof
patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom so this week's hatred
mail it does follow a common theme from
the hatreds but it's it's not as common
as just general homophobia or
anti-semitism it has to do with victim
complexes and being a triggered
snowflake take a listen to this David
Pakman is such a fool flop sore loser
the bottom line is this PAC face no
collusion
so now impeach Dave sociopath Pakman I
tell Vladimir I have more flexibility
after the election remember that I
condemn all anti-jewish attacks but
attacks on white Gentiles are the real
issue Jews are gas lighting you know for
a political movement that has made a big
deal out of not being easily triggered
and not constantly needing people to
provide safe spaces from them it's
amazing how this movement has grown
which claims that white Gentiles as the
Patriot says I guess we mean just people
who aren't Jewish have been sort of
really the victims in the United States
and in American society for five years
ten years twenty years I don't know how
long maybe dating all the way back to
the Civil Rights Act of 1964 you would
think that for people who purport to be
these ultimate alphas of all kinds and
in all ways they wouldn't be constantly
complaining about how they are actually
the victims in the United States of
America in any case you can take
patriotism and make it something good
for independent media by signing up for
a membership on our website using the
coupon code hey tree at forty h80 our
IOT 4-0 you save 40 percent when you use
that coupon code and the hey tree 'it's
hate it because they realize the
impotence of their hate hey tree at
forty on any membership at david
pakman.com slash membership it'll save
you forty percent